تشتعل الجبهات وتاتي اقوى الاشارات الرئيس
الاوكراني يتحدث عن تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه
ودفاعيه مضاده وفي موسكو يلقي الهجوم
المضاد بثقله على الكرملين وتتزايد
المخاطر السياسيه على الرئيس الروسي وفق
تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه ووفق
الصحيفه فان موسكو امام جبهه قتال على
الارض واخرى داخليه متوتره
ميدانيا تثير القوه الناريه للاسلحه
الغربيه الاوكرانيه توترا النخب الروسيه
كما تخشى احتماليه قطع جسر كيرش شريان
الحياه بين روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم اضافه
الى انتقال القوات الاوكرانيه من
زابوريجيا نحو ميلتوبل وصولا الى بحر ازوف
سيناريوهات تاتي في وقت تلقي الهجمات على
موسكو بالجرود الحدوديه وما يثار عن
انقسام بين قاده عسكريين روس بظلالها على
الداخل الروسي وضع تقول واشنطن بوست انه
يثير تساؤلات حول قدره بوتين على السيطره
عليه اذ بدت علامات التوتر المتزايد تظهر
حين اعلن عضو مؤثر في البرلمان الروسي
مقرب من المخابرات الروسيه ان روسيه فشلت
حتى الان في جميع اهدافها وبدا لافتا ايضا
ما نقلته الصحيفه عن مصدر مقرب من الدوائر
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه قوله ان هناك اشارات
متواضعه ظهرت على ان موسكو قد تكون مستعده
لتقديم بعض التنازلات يزداد التوتر ايضا
وفق الصحيفه في ظل دعم غربي متواصل لكييف
بالاسلحه كبديل لعضويه النيتو الفوريه ما
يعني تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا وهو ما يبدد ما
كان يعول عليه بوتين في تراجع الدعم
الغربي مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات